Isn't it a rabbit?
[Music]
Hey, who is that blue fluffy animal? It's the
baby of a blue grizzly.Actually, I've
been living a survival life in a forest full of monsters for a while, and I've been listening to it. Inugami,
Senpai, Usa, you,
you, touch this baby.  Can I take a look at it? Yes, it's okay. I'm
quiet, so if you bite me, I'll
fix it, so don't say anything scary.
I'm supposed to be a heroine, so when it comes to animals, this
guy looks at people and doesn't get depressed.
Don't get depressed.  It looks like she's just excited by the feel of his paws.Next
time, let's call her by her name.By
the way, her name is
Brun, which is a very nice name.Let's get
along.Ruri.Perhaps your
senior's heart is dirty.  Maybe,
hey Bull, that's enough. That's okay. It
seems like Usa-kun's heart is dirty too, so it's fine.
DET